what's up guys back on the road leaving
california i mean currently in
california but leaving california to
head back home to las vegas
um it's always such a bittersweet moment
bitter because i leave my family and
friends behind but sweet because i just
love living in vegas so far everything
just seems to be
so toned down and right now where our
life is
tone down and mellow and chill and slow
um is what we need but don't get me
wrong anytime i go back to california
specifically los angeles um and more
specifically downtown area of los
angeles i get super inspired just
because everything is so [ __ ] cool
and so trendy and so forward-thinking so
it's just a different headspace that i'm
in but once i get enough of that it's
always nice to remove myself from it and
kind of go back into parent mode and
stuff and speaking of parent mode i have
papa in my rear view right there
side view i'm so sorry side view and
he's also following
in uh following me going back to vegas
because he came early
and was out here shooting just kidding
news uh i want to see a few days before
we came down because i'm i'm really tied
to tyka's school schedule and if you
remember what school was like
it's been a minute for me for sure um
monday through friday you're pretty much
locked down
you know from eight
to three o'clock and then he has
practice so there's just a lot going on
during the week so uh whenever there is
a holiday like there was this past week
or this week that we're in now
i try to take advantage of that and head
back to cali to meet with friends and
family
um but no i had my film my cub is full
of just so much joy and inspiration
and love from from just heading back
that i'm ready to tackle the day
or the week ahead um ironically enough i
will be back that weekend just because
uh one of our friends daughters is
turning one
and um
and yeah of course we have to celebrate
with them so we'll be back but for now
taika is actually with papa
and he's my travel buddy dude like
i love traveling with him i love hearing
him in the background talking he wants
to hear his specific songs uh he'll ask
me funny questions right now he's really
into spider-man if you guys haven't
noticed
so he'll be talking about the newest
spider-man the one
spoiler alert that has all three
spider-man in it and he's waiting for it
to drop on
uh our apple streaming i don't know if
it's a streaming service or just apple
tv
you know apple tv has like all these
different networks and stuff in it um so
every time we can we check to see if
it's been released so that we can watch
it again because i did take him to the
movie theater um to check it out when it
was
whoa
when it was out oh i'm sorry um i look
so [ __ ] irresponsible right now but
i'm actually on
in my tesla and it's driving itself so
for sure
i have my eyes on the road
and uh but i just don't need i don't
need to to to do anything to steer or
anything um and every time you hear a
chime like a doom dunk dunk that's the
car communicating to me like hey check
this out or you need to change lanes or
i don't know put your hands on the
steering wheel are you still there so
those are the ding ding ding ding chimes
that you guys hear
um so yeah i miss my travel buddy the
space in there is [ __ ] empty and i'm
just like
duty but i also really do love when
tycho wants to be around his papa so um
he wanted to be with his dad i was more
than happy to do that but my selfish
side is going oh my buddy
so i've been listening to um a podcast
and i love this drive because it forces
me to be in the present moment because
you know um as a business owner and as
someone that
like you guys right like you guys live
online
you're constantly thinking of
you know what to post what's happening
online like you feel
i can only speak for myself so i'm going
to change that because i feel like fomo
if i'm not online i'm going wait what am
i missing out on
but yeah the point is my head is usually
in a million different places instead of
where it needs to be and that is in the
moment in the now present a hundred
percent so uh when i do have this long
trip ahead of me which is a four hour
drive from
where we where my parents or my mom
lives to
um our home in vegas it is a four
five hour four hour drive um
it does get a little bit longer when you
do drive a tesla though because um
depending on what year your car is so
for example mine is a 2018
the battery life starts or yeah the
battery life starts dying on it a little
bit so the mileage that you once had
you can start reducing it by like five
ten percent so
um what once was uh one stop
in between the trip
which would make it a five hour long
trip now there's two stops because i
need a little additional mileage to get
home so
it's fine if you have that time to spare
but if you don't be advised
you can start panicking because you're
like [ __ ] i told them i was gonna be
there four hours but it's taking six
sometimes maybe even eight oh [ __ ] yeah
so just be advised but
nonetheless i'm happy to be present
happy to be going back home
feeling good about the whole thing
all right so
first stop is at
eddie's world i'm pulling up on it
taika's favorite stop i'm not gonna lie
it's my favorite to stop too
um
they sell a ton of candy i've done so
many vlogs of this place
check them out
but if
you're taking a road trip to
um
vegas in your tesla from california this
is a really cool spot
um everything's very clean as you can
see
there's a bunch of
um
gas pumps here
and then
back here so it's all on the same lot
so as you can see the eddy's world
building is there and then this is all
the charging dang cool truck bro
uh this is where we charge here
so look at all this so you're never
alone i've been here at all hours
and it's always really clean and really
full of cool people with cool cars i'm
part of the club
okay i'm going to church now
[Music]
here are my dudes
my little my little fan club
hey cutie pie
how is it riding with papa
good you look like you just woke up
you took him out tell
oh
how do you like riding with him is this
your first time just youtube yeah it's
cuny isn't it cool yeah we just get to
we get to talk about kenny's stuff
and i get to teach them about all kinds
of chinese stuff we go how do you say
this in chinese how do you say that can
i say grandpa
[Music]
okay
good job okay let's go get some food and
snack-a-woo
that's the pee-pee he says oh good job
let's go
all right we're gonna grab some food
here and tyka's favorite
pizza
is on the menu
oh my god
oh that's a stringy pizza that dude
is happy are you happy
oh yeah
what is what's on papa's pizza again
what's this one
wow what about this one
what about that one
where's the avocado which is avocado
you tell me that you got some with
avocado he was like his pizza looks very
strange it has avocado on it i'm like
it's not avocado duty
my mine's
my yours is straight forward huh you
know what's on your pizza what's on your
pizza cheese oh yeah
okay so we are at another stop let me
get here because it's really windy um
initially i was gonna make it without
making it a a stop but i think my car so
i was gonna have like five percent
battery left and i think my car was like
navic you're risking it way too much so
it wants to give me like 15 so because
of that i had to stop and baker and this
one's not as cute let me show you
what are you doing
oh
yeah this one's not as cute
it's kind of like this it looks a little
sketch
because there's like graffiti and stuff
yes it looks
a little bit scarier what is this
i don't know what this one is why are
there like
these cars on this side but then there's
a shell on that side
very interesting
this guy went beepy yeah
i like the way i
mean our cars look why because it's
they're so different
it's literally us
that one's like a monster
that going that one yeah that one yeah
it's ready to go do something
and yours like
[Music]
it that's all mine does
already dude all ready
so we just got home emma and my
and this guy is already just tearing it
up i love leaving the house super clean
to my standards um
and coming back and not doing anything
okay well i do actually like to okay
okay
yeah
cool
okay wait no actually i like to unpack
and
then i'm ready to just chill out so
that's what i'm gonna do right now i'm
gonna pack
wash some clothes
call it a night
it's a flak
okay so we just finished having dinner
excuse me excuse me
and right now we're going to play a game
what are we going to play
okay who's going to seek you okay who's
going to hide
us
i'm going to go upstairs
okay make sure to turn on all the lights
don't don't tell them where you're gonna
go okay where am i gonna count to what
number um
twenty twenty twenty twenty twenty
twenty four
what okay ready i'm gonna count
go for it
one two
three
four
five i'll be back thirteen he told me i
was counting too fast fourteen
fifteen i can hear him upstairs 16
17
18
19
20
ready or not
here i come
[Music]
okay i think they're both upstairs
i don't think they'd be hiding up there
i feel like they both went upstairs
haha where can they be
you hear him i heard something
you're upstairs
he's learning how to play
i didn't hear you
i'm here
yeah my team okay let's look for papa
yeah
i saw someone
monkey you're supposed to stay quiet
because if i find you that means you
lose you're going to jump no i'm okay
yeah
i got you you put me in the laundry he
put you in the laundry room yeah okay
that's a pretty good spot if you didn't
if you didn't say anything i wouldn't
have found you yeah
where's papa i'm a little scared
you're a little scared
i'm spreading your mouth no but it's not
on okay let's see we're probably yeah
so papa's a little chubby right now oh
my god you scared me
okay so he definitely can't fit under
the bed no he's i could put on there but
and then i forgot to
hide under the bed
okay let's go look for him
you think he's over here
no oh okay
yeah those are my sweats
excuse you
okay let's go look for him
here
where do you think he went no do you
think he's in here
he has to be in here if you put you in
the laundry room he has to be here
um
oh you think you saw him over there i
didn't know i saw a shadow
oh he's here but he wasn't
oh maybe he's in the office
wait a minute something looks kind of
fat over here
something looks kind of bad over here
his was good how did you find how did
she find you he was like i'm over here
i'm in here i saw you
why did you give away your spot mama
wasn't gonna find it though so yeah
there was no way i was gonna find you
yeah but oh here we put me in there
okay we'll do it again
so i found them
i found you in literally three minutes
okay now you count yeah
okay now it's pablo's turn i have really
good spots
all right it's my turn one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
19 20 ready or not here i come so
earlier
we ran upstairs
so mama came upstairs now
it's my turn
to go
downstairs
to find them let's see
do you guys see anything
out of the ordinary
hmm
all right
everything seems pretty normal down here
right
okay
let's see
let's first check the closet
okay
all right let's see here
oh the lights on and the bathroom
maybe that's something
nope
but i do hear something on this end
keep hearing rustling
keep hearing rustling do you guys hear
rustling
like
let's see
let's see here
okay
no one's in there
what could be rustling leaves
yep
but
there could also be
let's see
there's a good spot in here
in this room that i like to hide in
let's see if anyone's in here
because usually i like to hide in here
oh
damn they're getting really good ma bear
believe it or not is really good
at hiding too
so we'll see
okay
no one in here
let's see
okay so i definitely
feel like someone's in here i think
let's see
i definitely think someone's in here
i know you heard me fart
how are you gonna get up there i don't
damn really it's one of those oh
okay oh let me see i gotta start
checking down wait did at least hide it
today really stand up i think you stood
out damn it yeah definitely not in here
i even heard you saying good things
about me
no i said you're really that's how
advanced our play is now that you have
to open up cabinets no it's really
really good it's really really good
especially
am i missing something
okay am i missing something
okay no point of going in the rush
wow
nope
[Music]
she's lying
let's see
let's see dang this is really good
ah don't dip me
don't
dupe me
because they're getting really good so
i'm i can't i got to leave every
oh my god that was so good
that was
good i didn't even know i was just
peeling back the layers
that was good
good job monkey
[Applause]
okay it's like his turn you're gonna
count to 20 right yeah okay
[Music]
let's see how this goes
[Music]
huh
oh
um
a software
[Music]
mama's big it's really hard to find her
i mean it's hard to hide her
mama
they're inside the castro
i like his commentary
dude this is so obvious
right next to me i mean i can't believe
it he's four years old
i try not to make it hard for him
but i guess i'm too good
he thinks he found me huh
oh man i messed up good job dude
a best spot i need to fight okay i need
to hide in a better spot next time thank
you
okay so we're playing another round of
hide-and-go-seek papa's counting now and
i think i found the best spot for tyga
papa you're you're paused right
okay
okay time in
it's looking real good
all right so
found mama so far yep
let's see
are these our kids big enough
oh i heard something
you can never be too careful
you know what i'm talking about
and that would be two
careful with these guys in here
and then be too
careful
oh
all right
you never be too careful right here huh
can't find them
it's gonna be real hard
it's gonna be real hard
might have just
what are you doing
turn on the light i'm getting scared ah
he's good
he's real good
it's real good oh this is boom but
this is pretty cool
hold on i'll get you down
you can put a mom up here that's a
really good spot thank you
good job dude okay we got to get him
down
he didn't win
that's awesome
okay wait wait i'll get you down
that was really good
we did it monkey we got him
it's it's it's it's
give you the dance give me the dance
your victory done
[Music]
we are real competitive in this house no
one likes losing here and i like that so
we got to get really creative
and papa
got some bobesies
what's wrong with this guy why does he
fart so much
so if there's one piece of advice that i
could give you
to make your life easy when entering a
monday
is
set yourself up what is going on
jesus
oh
stop
[Laughter]
set yourself up for success the night
before and as much as you can do that
obviously that's going to be better for
you but sunday night make sure to get
everything ready for the morning so
you're not rushing out so if that means
getting a mug out because you're going
to drink coffee every morning getting
the mug out setting the spoon
if it's the routine just have it ready
for you if it's closed get those ready
set all of those up pick out the outfit
yeah let me see
that's a big grapefruit
what did you say his name was
um what was i saying oh yeah pick out
the outfit tonight or because today's
sunday for us uh but yeah pick out the
outfit right the shoes the socks the
underwear um whatever it is that you're
gonna put on the morning get that ready
clean your space clean your kitchen make
sure everything is where it needs to be
it's clean everything's put away so that
you can have like these small little
wins already entering the week
trust me these little things
to help you
set yourself up for success
they really do go a long way it's like i
i feel like a lot of people
underestimate like these little these
little decisions these little
i don't know what to call them like
these little these little ellie hoops
these little setups
um and they they try to focus too much
on the big picture like get promoted or
get whatever get like you know what i
mean but it really does take all these
little habits
and they all start like
uh
uh
compounding on one another and creating
a better you a better version of you an
easier life for you
and it allows you
to free up mental space and bandwidth
so that you can what
okay we'll turn off
i feel rushed here i'm sorry so that you
can achieve whatever it is that you're
trying to go for okay i'm getting kicked
out i'm sorry all right we're gonna put
this kid to bed okay we're turning off
the lights now okay let's go
okay dude
okay
now
it's
mama bear
and papa bear's turn
[Laughter]
whoa no
he's done
okay so
euphoria has it already aired its season
finale i am behind
two episodes
i've been avoiding
instagram
of like any euphoria anything i've just
been avoiding it so i don't know what to
expect i'm about to watch it
i know that was beyonce okay now it
changed to something else
i don't know if my heart can take it are
you ready
how many blankets are in here okay me
and sega were cold okay dude
there's like four of them
holy crap i was scared he was gonna pee
on your side of the bed oh thank you
okay here is this my old blanket that's
inside
i have no idea old see through one no i
think that one's then what's inside here
i have no idea because yours is right
here no it's a thinner one this is the
old one i have two of them
it is kind of comfy
okay i'm gonna watch it brb b r
[ __ ] b oh my god oh my god oh my
god oh my god oh my god
that's so funny
okay so as you can see
he's already getting ready for bed just
finished the episode we were only able
to catch up on season okay episode seven
out of the eight
we're still one behind this is lexi's
play
and
jake just walked out
and ended it with cass oh spoiler alert
but i don't know what's gonna happen
did you really end up with her
oh god i was so good
why can't this be like four hours long
how am i gonna sleep tonight
knowing that there's one more episode
okay dude
okay on that note
good night
oh god look at how comfy this looks
so comfy
so comfy
good night